ça y est on est au mois de janvier alors
grossièrement à ce stade de la vidéo je
dirais qu'il y a deux options soit vous
avez lu le titre vous avez parfaitement
compris de quoi je veux parler et vous
êtes venus chercher des conseils et dans
ce cas-là bah rester parce que c'est
exactement ce qui va se passer soit vous
avez le titre vous êtes demandé ce que
je pouvais bien raconter et vous êtes
venu par curiosité et dans ce cas là
restez aussi parce que vous allez
apprendre des trucs et que ça vous
concernement ou que ça vous concernera
un jour ou l'autre ou quelqu'un que vous
connaissez bref restez
[Musique]
on va commencer tout de suite par poser
un peu le contexte pour les gens qui
savent pas trop de quoi on parle le mois
de janvier c'est le pire moi de l'année
c'est l'un des mois les plus sombres de
l'année là on parle de soleil et de
luminosité mais c'est aussi le mois le
plus froid de l'année le mois où on
déprime le plus et le mois où on meurt
le plus désolé je prends pas de
pincettes mais il y a des choses qu'il
faut dire sans fioriture c'est vrai
depuis des années pour des raisons sur
lesquelles on va revenir et vous allez
vite comprendre que cette année ça vous
êtes encore plus vrai que d'habitude de
20 janvier c'est le mois où on se remet
des fêtes qui sont toujours l'occasion
pour ce combat de famille de se rappeler
que ça leur manque et pour ceux qui ont
passé le réveillon avec leur famille
horrible de se rappeler que ça leur
manque pas dans tous les cas si ça a été
nul on est triste et si ça a été trop
bien bah on est triste aussi parce que
c'est fini avec en plus cette espèce de
redescente là genre gueule de bois avec
des primes des lendemains de fait quand
on a trop abusé mais en x 1000 parce que
oui on a abusé et pas qu'une fois bref
globalement tout le monde est plus ou
moins dans le mal physiquement et
mentalement certains plus que d'autres
c'est sûr mais c'est pas un concours et
là en plus on arrive gentiment en
janvier avec trois belles années de
merde dans les gens trois belles années
de merde avec trois trucs bien pourri
qui ont sérieusement détérioré nos santé
physique et mentales le covid et ses
conséquences notamment sociales et
humaines d'abord ça ça fait exploser le
nombre de cas de troubles anxieux et de
dépression sans parler des covids longs
la prise de conscience généralisée de
l'urgence climatique et de l'inaction de
ceux qui devrait faire quelque chose
chose qui a miné encore plus le moral
d'une grande partie de la population et
pour finir la guerre en Ukraine et
l'augmentation des prix du gaz et de
l'électricité qui va avec tout ça dans
un contexte de baisse du pouvoir d'achat
généralisé avec des ministres qui
viennent nous parler de sobriété
énergétique en doudoune ou en col roulé
à 500 balles ouais la sobriété
énergétique c'est nouveau un truc qui
est pas nouveau par contre c'est ce
qu'on appelle la précarité énergétique
ça on connaît depuis longtemps et on
sait que ça a un impact négatif sur la
santé physique et mentale des gens que
ça touche surtout le mois le plus froid
de l'année et quand on regarde bien la
frontière entre sobriété et énergétique
et précarité énergétique pour un certain
nombre de personnes c'est
c'est pas évident bon voilà donc c'est
le pire mois de l'année et vous le
commencez en regardant cette vidéo et
j'ai bien conscience d'avoir rajouté une
couche à ce mille-feuille au caca qui
est janvier j'ai chié l'ambiance de
manière pâtissière mais je suis
l'ambiance mais l'idée vous avez bien
compris en lisant titre de la vidéo
c'est de trouver des solutions pour
tenir bon alors on passe tout de suite
au conseil pour survivre au mois de
janvier on va commencer avec des trucs
plutôt pratique et vous allez voir il y
en a qui marche pas forcément tout de
suite donc on finira avec des tips pour
tenir le coup en attendant que ça marche
donc restez bien jusqu'au bout et même
s'il y a des trucs dans ce que je vais
vous dire qui peuvent vous paraître
anecdotique oubliez pas deux choses
faire un tout petit truc bénéfique ça a
un tout petit peu d'effet mais faire
plein de tout petits trucs bénéfiques de
manière répétée ça a beaucoup d'effet
et l'inverse aurait aussi et puis tout
est lié si vous êtes déprimé vous tombez
malade plus facilement et si vous êtes
malade vous avez tendance à déprimer
l'idée c'est de casser la dynamique
négative et d'entrer dans une spirale
vertueuse je parle comme un livre je
sais pas ce qui m'arrive alors le froid
d'abord parce que tout le monde a part
un logement bien isolé et que vu les
prix du gaz et de l'électricité même
sans parler de faire des économies
d'énergie souvent c'est juste faire des
économies tout court en fait du coup on
chauffe moins et on se les pèle même à
l'intérieur on a froid chez nous donc
l'idée c'est de bien s'habiller alors la
doudoune c'est bien gentil mais quand on
est chez soi en train de manger c'est
pas ouf et en plus c'est pas le plus
efficace quand il fait froid le mieux
c'est d'adopter la technique de l'oignon
pas faire pleurer et donner des gaz
horribles juste mettre plusieurs couches
de vêtements en fait il faut mettre 3
couches de vêtements parce que si on en
met trop on risque de transpirer et
quand on transpire on a froid le but des
trois couches c'est de garder enfermé de
l'air contre nous qui va se réchauffer
avec notre chaleur corporelle et rester
en place pour nous faire comme un petit
chauffage personnel la première couche
celle qui est contre nous elle doit resp
elle doit laisser passer la
transpiration pour pas la garder contre
nous la deuxième couche elle doit isoler
c'est à dire qu'elle doit garder la
chaleur de notre corps comme on a dit et
la troisième couche si c'est pour aller
dehors elle doit être imperméable pour
pas être mouillé mais si c'est pour
rester à l'intérieur bah il faut juste
qu'elle empêche le froid de rentrer
aérer oui je sais ça a l'air taré et
complètement contradictoire avec ce que
je viens de dire mais si on est plus
malade en hiver c'est aussi parce qu'on
a à r moins à cause du froid du coup
l'air il est blindé de virus qui reste à
l'intérieur comme ça en vaselot et en
plus il y a un truc qu'on appelle la
pollution de l'air intérieur dont je
vous avais déjà parlé dans ma vidéo sur
les conséquences du confinement je vous
remets les liens dans la description
mais pour commencer à aérer un peu tous
les jours bien manger alors qu'est-ce
qu'on mange quand il fait froid
évidemment les classiques les
intemporels les fruits et légumes de
saison bien sûr ça on en a besoin de
base pour faire fonctionner la machine
en hiver n'hésitez pas à faire des
soupes par exemple et à boire beaucoup
parce que le froid ça déshydrate par
contre buvez pas des trucs trop chaud
contrairement à ce qu'on pense ça ça va
avoir tendance dans un deuxième temps à
nous refroidir donc buvez plutôt tiède
ou froid si c'est de l'eau c'est bien
l'eau c'est bien et méfiez-vous de
l'alcool on a l'impression que ça
réchauffe et en fait c'est exactement le
contraire pour le reste bah penser que
votre corps il va avoir besoin d'énergie
pour lutter contre le froid donc manger
comme un sportif féculent et protéines
ritante protéine végétales c'est bien
aussi et puis des fruits secs mais
contrairement à ce qu'on pense il n'y a
pas besoin de manger plus quand il fait
froid pas plus de calories et pas plus
de graisse non plus on a déjà tendance à
manger trop là il faut juste manger bien
en fait ah oui et puis même si vous avez
abusé pendant les fêtes n'oubliez pas
que vous avez le droit de vous faire
plaisir de temps en temps c'est janvier
c'est le pire des mois vous avez le
droit on en reparle à la fin de la vidéo
ne pas négliger sa santé oui ça a l'air
con on dit comme ça mais en 2014 18% des
Français disaient avoir déjà renoncé à
se faire soigner faute d'argent en 2018
c'était plus de 30% et depuis la crise
du covid ça augmente encore ce qui
bloque souvent les gens c'est les
médecins chez qui il faut avancer les
frais avant d'être remboursé par la sécu
et puis la somme qui reste à leur charge
après avoir été remboursé normalement
financièrement c'est pas la fête ces
derniers temps mais si on laisse traîner
un problème de santé il va avoir une
salle tendance à s'aggraver alors si
vous voulez vous faire soigner sans
avoir à sortir votre portefeuille faut
savoir qu'il y a des maisons de santé
qui existent si vous avez une mutuelle
mais aussi des centres de soins qui sont
ouverts à tous et ça ça vous permet
d'avoir des rendez-vous sans avoir à
avancer les frais je vous ai mis des
liens dans la description pour pouvoir
en trouver un près de chez vous et puis
un lien pour avoir des aides financières
aussi éventuellement ne pas négliger sa
santé mentale bah oui ne pas négliger sa
santé ça veut dire aussi ne pas négliger
sa santé mentale parce que je rappelle
que tout est lié même problème ça coûte
cher et c'est mal remboursé voir pas du
tout depuis le covid on a droit à des
séances remboursées chez un ou chez une
psychologue si on a une ordonnance de
son médecin traitant il y en a pas
beaucoup c'est des séances courtes c'est
pas idéal mais c'est mieux que rien
sinon bah il y a les CMP ou on peut
avoir des consultations gratuites le
problème c'est que c'est souvent long
pour avoir un rendez-vous d'autant plus
qu'on manque de psy un peu partout mais
je vous ai quand même mis un lien vers
une carte dans la description de la
vidéo alors comme je vous ai dit tout ça
ça marche pas forcément tout de suite du
coup qu'est-ce qu'on fait pour tenir le
coup en attendant et ben on va essayer
de sécréter un maximum de substances qui
nous aide à nous sentir bien des
substances naturelles je vous vois venir
comme la dopamine par exemple la
dopamine on en a déjà parlé plein de
fois c'est un neurotransmetteur c'est
une substance chimique qui permet à nos
neurones de communiquer entre eux et sa
spécialité c'est de faire circuler les
informations qui concernent le plaisir
c'est même pour ça qu'on l'appelle
l'hormone du plaisir alors que c'est pas
une hormone mais bon bref il y a aussi
la sérotonine l'hormone du bonheur
l'ocytocine l'hormone de l'amour etc etc
on produit plein de substances de genre
là et retenez surtout ça moins vous en
sécrétez plus vous êtes fatigué plus
vous êtes déprimé donc moins vous avez
envie de faire tous ces trucs qui vont
justement libérer toutes ces substances
et qui font que vous allez vous sentir
mieux et que vous allez trouver la force
de faire d'autres trucs qui vont vous
faire vous sentir encore mieux etc c'est
pour ça que faire plein de petits trucs
ça vous permet de sortir progressivement
du marécage et de sortir petit à petit
du cercle vicieux pour entrer dans un
cercle vertueux parce que vous retrouvez
l'envie d'avoir envie comme disait le
poète
ok mais alors qu'est-ce qui nous fait
sécréter c'est délicieuse drogue légale
du bonheur la lumière du jour déjà et
ouais c'est pas un hasard si le mois le
plus sombre de l'année c'est aussi celui
où on déprime le plus souvent on part de
chez nous le matin il fait nuit on
rentre chez nous le soir il fait nuit
alors les lampes de luminothérapie
pourquoi pas mais le plus efficace pour
stimuler la sécrétion de toutes ces
substances dont je viens de vous parler
c'est la lumière naturelle
le soleil donc dès que vous pouvez
sortez aux heures où il fait jour même
si il fait gris ça vous fera du bien et
ça m'amène directement au Conseil
suivant l'activité physique ça augmente
la sécrétion de dopamine et de
sérotonine et ça en diminue d'autres
comme celle du cortisol qui est
l'hormone du stress alors au début vous
n'êtes pas obligé d'aller soulever des
tonnes de fonte à la salle juste quand
vous sortez choper votre petite dose
quotidienne de lumière du jour
profitez-en pour marcher une petite
demi-heure et au fil des jours vous y
allez crescendo et si vous le sentez
bien sûr vous en faites un peu plus
chaque jour l'orgasme oui bon déjà ça
implique plus ou moins une activité
physique donc on est bien et puis en
termes de sécrétion de trucs cool
l'orgasme ça se pose là je vous renvoie
à la vidéo que j'avais fait sur le sujet
vous allez voir c'est open bar pour
obtenir un orgasme il y a plusieurs
possibilités soit vous faites ça avec
une un ou des partenaires consentante et
consentant évidemment soit vous vous
débrouillez tout seul avec ou sans
accessoire mais si vous préférez avec
prenez des un truc qui sont prévus pour
eux ça vous évitera de finir aux
urgences la chaleur humaine si le sexe
c'est pas votre truc c'est possible bah
sachez que non seulement voir du monde
discuter échanger rigoler etc ça fait du
bien mais qu'en plus quand on a un
contact physique avec quelqu'un qu'on
aime bien on sécrète de l'ocytocine et
l'ocytocine ça favorise la sécrétion de
sérotonine qui stabilise l'humeur et qui
aide à lutter contre le stress donc
sortez de chez vous marchez un petit peu
prenez la lumière l'air frais etc et
rejoignez quelqu'un que vous aimez bien
pour discuter faire un petit HUG et plus
si affinités et hop combo si vraiment
vous êtes misanthrope ça marche aussi
avec les animaux je parle pas de
l'orgasme juste un câlin petite caresse
petite patoune voilà voilà tout ça c'est
des moyens de sécréter des substances
qui vont vous aider à vous sentir mieux
ça va pas régler vos problèmes mais ça
va vous aider à tenir le coup en
attendant de le faire juste si vous
étiez tenté de prendre un raccourci en
vous disant que après boire un petit
coup ça fait à peu près le même effet et
bah sachez que non ça n'est pas une
bonne idée l'alcool sur le moment c'est
anxiolytique ça rend joyeux etc mais dès
le lendemain c'est tout l'inverse ça
vous enfonce d'ailleurs si vraiment vous
avez forcé pendant les fêtes ça joue
aussi sur votre état après alors bien
sûr il reste toujours l'option de
reboire un petit coup le lendemain pour
que ça aille mieux puis le jour suivant
puis le jour d'après et ensuite mais ça
ça a un nom et c'est une maladie
souvenez-vous d'un truc l'alcool ça crée
plus de problèmes que ça non résout
vu que ça n'en résout jamais aucun un
autre petit truc tout ça tout ce qu'on
vient de se dire là c'est pour faire en
sorte que vous alliez mieux vous mais ce
qui est vachement bien surtout quand les
temps sont durs c'est de checker comment
les autres s'en sortent prenez des
nouvelles des gens autour de vous
surtout les plus fragiles et les plus
isolés mais pas seulement et donner un
coup de main en cas de besoin ne
serait-ce qu'un peu de chaleur humaine
vous souvenez ce qu'on a dit un petit
shot de cytocine ça fait toujours du
bien comme d'habitude je vous ai mis
plein de liens dans la description mes
vidéos sur l'orgasme sur la santé
mentale sur les crises d'angoisse etc
mais aussi des trucs pratiques pour
trouver des centres pour trouver des
aides des infos sur les sujets qu'on a
abordés et puis des petits conseils de
gens à regarder ou à écouter genre
stupide économics qui vous donne des
petits tips pour faire des économies ou
l'épisode du podcast de l'ENA situation
sur le blues hivernal vous allez voir ça
fait du bien d'entendre quelqu'un qui
parle de ce qu'on peut ressentir parfois
avec autant de sincérité et autant de
naturel allez deux derniers petits
conseils avant de vous laisser aller
vous balader tant qu'il fait jour
d'abord les une bonne résolution
alors la base c'est une bonne idée mais
faut pas faire ça n'importe comment
faire une liste de ce que vous voulez
améliorer dans votre vie c'est plutôt
bien mais vous mettez pas la pression
non plus si vous placez la barre trop
vous allez faire comme l'ONU plein de
résolution 0 de respecter donc soyez
raisonnable prioriser et étalez vos
résolutions dans le temps en commençant
par des trucs qui sont faisables vous
avez toute l'année pour changer des
trucs dans votre vie vous n'êtes pas
obligé de tout faire en janvier c'est
déjà un mois assez compliqué comme ça
foutez vous la paix et deuxième conseil
faites-vous plaisir quand il fait froid
quand il fait sombre quand on est pas
bien quel que soit la raison faut penser
à se faire du bien et à être sympa avec
soi-même demandez-vous de quoi vous avez
besoin de quoi vous avez envie là tout
de suite et si ça déroge à une de vos
résolutions c'est juste une dérogation
c'est pas un échec et en plus ça vous
laisse une marge de progression pour les
prochains mois donc c'est nickel foutez
vous la paix oui je l'ai dit deux fois
donc vraiment foutez vous la paix
voilà DTC c'est fini pour aujourd'hui
j'espère que vous allez traverser le
mois de janvier le mieux possible on se
retrouve très vite pour de nouvelles
vidéos d'ici là prenez soin de vous et
prenez soin des autres mettez-vous bien
et surtout portez-vous bien
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]